sharyn à la parole et à monsieur jacques
alain bénisti ma question s'adresse au
ministre des transports ceci mot
collègues yves albarello monsieur mini
ce vous le savez les franciliens ont
terriblement souffert la semaine
dernière pendant plusieurs jours d'une
fermeture totale du réseau sur la partie
nord du rer b cette ligne vous le savez
transporte habituellement près d'un
million de passagers tous les jours à
destination des aéroports charles de
gaulle deuxième aéroport d'europe et
premier de france touristes voyageurs
d'affaires mais aussi usagers quotidiens
travaillant sur la ligne ont subi en
fait la double peine car il n'avait même
pas la possibilité de prendre leur
véhicule puisqu'une mesures de
circulation alternée était également en
vigueur au même moment sans qu'aucune
décision de des de l'annuler n'ait été
prise alors comme d'habitude chacun se
renvoie la balle la sncf bien sûr de son
côté indique que c'était un
dysfonctionnement des caténaires
alors que lors des travaux récents qui
avait engagé des investissements
financiers considérables de l'état
eh bien il avait simplement omis de
changer ses caténaires défectueuse et
l'état d'un autre côté qui botte
évidemment comme d'habitude en touche en
reportant la responsabilité sur la sncf
qui ne cesse de dire quel manque de
moyens faute d'arbitrage pour assurer
ses missions essentielles sur réseau en
tant qu élu francilien monsieur le
ministre mais aussi en tant que
représentant la nation je ne peux me
satisfaire d'un tel défaut de l'état qui
a contraint des centaines de milliers de
franciliens a renoncé à aller travailler
aussi monsieur le ministre quelles sont
les mesures concrètes que vous allez
prendre pour éviter qu'un tel fiasco ne
recommence et qu'une fois de plus
l'image de la france ne soit ternie et
ridiculisé devant des millions de
touristes qui ont pourtant choisi de
venir dans notre beau pays mais aussi la
parole et à monsieur alain vidalies
secrétaire d'état chargé des transports
de la mer et de la pêche
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
député effectivement la semaine dernière
nous avons
un incident grave sur le rer b est
d'ailleurs dans les jours qui ont suivi
un autre incident à la gare du nord j'ai
immédiatement demandé que des expertises
indépendantes soit organisé ce que je
peux vous dire aujourd'hui c'est que
s'agissant du rer b la première que des
premières conclusions mettent en cause
effectivement le caténaire et je rendrai
public dans les prochains jours
l'ensemble de ses expertises pour
qu'elle soit partagée par tous les élus
le constat il est très simple nous
sommes confrontés à un vieillissement du
réseau
ce vieillissement du réseau il est le
résultat de choix qui ont été faits
depuis des décennies et notamment à un
moment donné du choix de privilégier la
construction simultanée de quatre lignes
tgv ce qui fait qu'en 2007 il y avait
simplement 3 milliards pour l'ensemble
des crédits de maintenance pour le
réseau mais quand on parle de
maintenance on confond souvent deux
choses d'une part l'entretien courant et
d'autre part le renouvellement comme il
n'y avait pas d'assez l'argent dans ces
années là on a privilégié uniquement
l'entretien courant sans faire de
renouvellement ce gouvernement a pris
les choses en main nous sommes
aujourd'hui en 2007 il y avait 3
milliards au total aujourd'hui en
approche 4 milliards 9 dans deux
milliards sept pour simplement le
renouvellement et je le dis clairement
il faudra poursuivre cet effort au moins
pendant huit ans et de manière
privilégiée sur l'île de france c'est ce
que le gouvernement souhaite faire c'est
ce que le premier ministre m'a demandé
de mettre en oeuvre j'ajoute que nous
avons recruté simplement sur l'île de
france 1200 agents depuis 2012 alors
monsieur le député les choses sont
simples
moi je ne crois pas qu'on puisse être le
dimanche et le lundi sur les estrades en
disant il faut faire 100 milliards
d'économie d'argent public il ne faut
pas de service public et venir ici et là
vous avez raison et je vous rejoins dire
qu'il faut plus d'état qu'il faut plus
de services publics mais c'est bien ce
que ce gouvernement et cette majorité
met en oeuvre